[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا الكرام السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
وبركاته اسعد الله اوقاتكم بكل خير اهلا
بكم في هذه المقابله الخاصه مع رئيس مجلس
القياده الرئاسي الدكتور رشاد محمد علي
الدكتور رشاد اهلا وسهلا بك
سعيد بتواجدك معي في هذا اللقاء
قناه العربيه بهذا اللقاء وهو الاول بعد
التسلل هذا المجلس ثاني يبدا معك فخامه
الرئيس
في اليمن ومصير هذه الهدنه ومالاتها اليوم
في بدايه اكتوبر الماضي اعلنت الامم
المتحده فشل جهودها لتمديد الهدنه في
اليمن بعد جولات مكوكيه المحادثات استمر
لماذا انهارتو فشلت الهدنه في اليمن
نحن كما تعرف عندما تشكل مجلس القياده
الرئاسي كانت الهدنه قائمه وقمنا بتجديد
هذه المدينه من طرف الحكومه الشرعيه
ولكن منذ اثنين اكتوبر الماضي همم
الميليشيات الحوثيه الارهابيه رفضت تمديد
الهدنه همم رغم كل الجهود اللي بدلت سواء
من الاشقه في قياده التحالف والمملكه
العربيه السعوديه بالدرجه الرئيسيه
والمبعوث الامريكي وجهود ايضا العمانيه
همم بدلات بهذا الاتجاه ولكن للاسف همم
رفضه الحوثيه وحتى هذه اللحظه
وطبعا كانت هي هشه
لانه الهدنه قامت على ثلاث عناصر رئيسيه
العنصر الاول كان فتح مطار صنعاء الدولي
لاهلنا وفي صنعاء
والعنصر الثاني كان بناء الحديده
والمشتقات النفطيه والعنصر الثالث كان فتح
طرق تعزل المحاصره منذ سبع سنوات من قبل
الميليشيات
الرئيسيه
اللي من قبل الحكومه الشرعيه نفذناها فتح
مطار صنعاء همم
اهلنا ومواطنيننا ونحن كنا حريصين على فتح
مطار صنعاء وكان هناك مبادرات من الحكومه
الشرعيه من سنوات لفتح مطار صنعاء ولكن
كانت الميليشيات الحوثيه الارهابيه همم
كل همم هذه العروض وتتعذر باعذار وهي همم
ونحن
حريصين على ان يستفيد اهلنا همم في صنعاء
والمناطق المجاوره لها تحصيل طلبه
الحوثيين من اا من فتح مطار صنعاء
هم رفضوا ما يخصهم همم الحوثيين رفضوا فتح
طرق تحسس ولا زالت طرق تعز حتى هذه اللحظه
هذا اليوم ايضا خلال الهدنه كان هناك
خروقات متعدده في كل الجبهات وهناك مئات
الشهداء والجرحى من الجيش الوطني
والمقاومه والتشكيلات العسكريه في كل
الجبهات والرغم ذلك كنا نتحمل همم في
الحكومه الشرعيه والنتائج هذه الانتهاكات
همم
في ان همم
تستمر هذه الهدنه ونتقل الى وقت انطلاق
نار
مشاولات سياسيه تفضي الى السلام
والاستقرار الذي سيستفيد منه شعبا اليمني
في كل مكان اثناء جولات المفاوض التي كانت
تتم في موضوع الهدنه والتمديدها هل كان
الحوثيون يسرحون بمواقفهم يعني برفضها
بالتصعيد دائما في سواء كان على الارض او
حتى على طاوله المفاوضات اتمنى انها كانت
مماطله يعني تجري دون الحديد بشكل صريح
الموقفين منها
اولا هم لما يلتزمون بما يخصهم في مساله
الهنديه وهي فتحه طرق تعيش
وهذا بالنسبه لنا كان مبرر
موضوعي همم
لا نجدد وبالتالي همم ممكن نغلق مطار
صنعاء ونغلق ايضا ونوقف همم تدفق همم
المشقات النفطيه الى ميناء الحديده ونحن
نعرف ان ميناء الحديده بالنسبه للحوثي
والمشتقات النفطيه
يستفيد منها الحوثيين همم بعشرات او ربما
مئه مليون يعني على كل همم باخره نفط همم
يحصلون على حوالي خمسه مليار
ريال يمني
وهذه كان يفترض وفقا الاتفاقيه السكر ان
كل ايرادات بناء الحمونيه الحديده تذهب
الى المرتبات
الخاضعين للسيطره ميليشيات الحوثيين
ولكن نحن عندما تشكل مجلس القياده الرئاسي
اعلنا في برنامجنا امام مجلس النواب ان
موضوع المرتبات هو موضوع رئيسي بالنسبه
لنا في مناطق سيطره الحسين وانه لا نرضى
ان يبقى اهلنا في هذه المناطق وموظفين
الموجودين هناك بدون مرتبه
وتعرف انت ان همم
للشيخ الحوثيه الارهابيه اكثر من 45 مليار
من البنك المركزي في الحديده وكان وفقا
الاتفاقيه السكون كانت مخصصه
لمرتبات الموظفين همم في مناطق سيطره
الميليشيات همم الارهابيين
والرغم ذلك هذه المليشيات ولم يحرك ساكنه
من المجلس الامن ولا حتى بيدانا لهذه
المبالغ الماليه التي نهي بها الحوثيون من
البنك المركزي فرع الحديده همم ويسخرونها
لخدمه
ماذا كان موقف الوسطاء الدوليين اثناء هذه
المفاوضات بانكم تلتزمون بشروط التهدئه
والهدنه في مقابل تصعيد وعدم التزام على
سبيل المثال موضوع الحصار في تعز وفتح
الطرق ما هو موقفه
في الواقع الموقف الدولي خالد انت تعرف
الموقف الدولي يضغط على الحكومه
الشرعيه ويضغط ايضا على قياده التحالف
ودائما خطابهم يقول انتم دوله انتم مؤسسه
انتم لديكم الالتزامات امام مجتمعكم
اليمني وامام المجتمع الدولي وبالتالي هذه
من الاشياءات همم ونحن عندما نضغط عليكم
كمؤسسه تحترم نفسها تحترم قوانينها تحترم
الدستورها تحترم شعبها لكن هذه الميليشيات
لا يبهون لاي شيء على الاطلاق طبعا هذا
مبررات ولكن همم كانت بتصدر ايدانت من هنا
وهناك سواء من المبعوثه
المبعوث الامريكي ايضا الاذان
[موسيقى]
ليست كافيه بالنسبه لهذه المشكله
لابد من لابد من افعال
تضغط على هذه الميليشيات للمجيء الى طاوله
المشاورات لايقاف الحرب لتحقيق السلام
والاستقرار للشعب اليمني هذا هو المطلوب
من المجتمع الدولي ومن المبعوث الاممي
والمبعوثه وليس الادامه
حتى الوسيط الامريكي
كلها في اطار الادانه لكن نحن نريد ان
ننتقل هذه
الاذنات الى افعال وهذا ما خاصه في
المجتمع الدولي
المجتمع الدولي خطبنا انه الاقوال ناتج في
معان هذه المنشات
المجتمع الدولي
نحن نطالب المجتمع الدولي ان يصنف هذه
الجماعه الارهابيه كجماعه ارهابيه هذه هذه
الجماعه الارهابيه هي جزء من الحرس الثوري
الايراني وهي جزء من حزب الله
هذه الجماعات مصنفه غير ارهابيين فلماذا
لا يصنف هذه الجماعه ارهابيه
للاسف كان اتخذت خطوه من قبل الاداره
الامريكيه السابقه بتصنيف هذه الجماعه
ارهابيه ولكن للاسف الاداده الجديده اتت
والغد وهذا التصنيف وهذا انا نحن اعتبرناه
للحوثيين نحن نقول المجتمع الدولي لا
تقدموا حوافز همم
الارهابيه لانها تتمادى اكثر كلما قدمت
لهم حوافز من المجتمع الدولي اول مجتمع
الاقليمي كلما هما غلبوا مصلحه ايران على
مصالح الشعب اليمني واستمروا في هذه
الاعمال الارهابيه وممارسه الانف ضد الشعب
اليمني ضد النساء ضد الاطفال ضد الممتلكات
الخاصه
والعامه همم كل هذه القضايا ارتكبتها وهي
لا تختلف عن ممارسات داعش والقاعده يعني
انت لما تقارن بين ما تعمل ما تعملوا هذه
الاشياء
وما تقوم به من افعال اجراميه ضد الشعب
اليمني وتقارنها بالافعال التي تقوم بها
منظمه القاعده وداعش ستجد انها لا تختلف
تماما عن هذه الممارسات وهنا كيف انت خادم
بينها وبين تنظيم القاعده وداعش واثبت ان
هذا عمليا يعني كان لدينا معتقلين محكوم
عليهم في قضايا ارهابيه ومنها الاعتداء
على المدمر الامريكيه اس اي سكول تم
الافراج
الارهابيه الحوثيين وتم ايضا تجويدهم
بالاسلحه والمعدات
واطلقوا همم وطلقوهم في اتجاه المناطق
اللي تحت السيطره الحكومه الشرعيه للقيام
بعمليات الارهابيه وحصل المواجهات بين هذه
العناصر وبين وحدات المكافحه الارهاب
وقتل حوالي ثمانيه من هذه العناصر في
الضاله واستشهد علينا حوالي خمسه
مكافحه الارهاب في الضاله
هذا نموذج فقط من التخادم بين تنظيم
القاعده وبين تنظيم داعش ونحن ابلغنا
المجتمع الدولي وكل الاجهزه الامنيه
ابلغتهم اجهزه من الاستقباليه بهذه
المعلومات كامله في الوقت الذي تقولون في
انتم بان عدم وجود ضغط دولي حقيقي اليوم
على الميليشيات الحوثيه اسهم في تماديها
في شارع الهدنه في تصعيدها في اكثر من
منطقه في استمرار حصارها على تعز وغيرها
من المناطق في هذا الوقت كذلك هناك من
يتهم الحكومه الشرعيه في اليمن والمجلس
بانه كذلك هو جزء من المشكله هو كذلك ادى
الى تمادي الحوثي بكل اجراءاته عن الارض
بمعنى لماذا تلتزمون انتم من طرفكم بكل
شروط التهدئه في مقابل عدم التزامهم وعدم
فك الحصار كشرد رئيسي من شروط استمرار هذه
الهدنه
صحيح اتفق معك
هناك الام
شعبي حتى في مناطق سيطره الحوثيين هناك
لهم شعبي على الحكومه الشرعيه وعلى المجلس
لماذا يقدم كل هذه التنازلات
والمنسيه الارهابيه لم تقدم هذا صحيح
والرغم ذلك نحن تحملنا هذا
واتخذنا هذه الخطوه
بهدف رفع المعاناه عن شعبنا اليمني الشعب
اليمني على شديده انسانيه خاصه في مناطق
سيطره الحوثيين
وبالتالي نحن وافقنا على استمرار
الهدنه في ظل تعلمته الحوثيين من اجل
مصلحه شعبنا اوله هذا رقم واحد
اشياء ثانيه من اجل فضح دعاوي هذه
المليشيات امام المجتمع الدولي
لانها كانت بتدعي انها جماعه مظلومه وانها
يعني وان وان هذه الحرب هي ظالمه عليها
اليوم توقفت الحرب من طرف واحد الا من قبل
الحوثيين استمر
الشعب اليمني اولا
وفضحها امام المجتمع الدولي انهم ليس
مشروع سلام ونحن نقول هذا الكلام المجتمع
الدولي نحن دلوعات سلام في مجلس القياده
وفي الحكومه وفي التحالف ولكن ليس لدينا
شريك
الى متى ستستمر
اليوم المجتمع الدولي بحاجه الى فضح هذه
المليشيات والصوره اصبحت واضح يعني في كل
مكان بالنسبه للحوثي كانت هناك كذلك
ممارسات لكسر
الهدنه كان وما زال ايضا هناك رفض لذلك
باستمرار في يزيد الملاحه البحريه فيها
اكثر المواطن يمني يقول لها متى
وبعدين يعني
ما رايك هذا السؤال اللي احنا بنطرحه في
مجلس القياده الرئاسي انا واخواني
بنناقشوا مناقشه مستفيضه ونناقش ايضا في
الحكومه
نحن في الواقع
نعتقد نعتقد
ان
مجلس الدفاع الوطني
التصعيد
في استهداف مشاهده
[موسيقى]
استهداف الملاحه الدوليه
استمرار الهجمات العسكريه على كل الجبهات
تمام هذا دفعنا الى عقد اجتماع لمجلس
الدفاع الوطني
مجلس الدفاع الوطني
يشكل من
همم الرئيس
واعضانك طبعا مجلس القياده الرئاسي الان
ورئيس مجلس النواب ورئيس الحكومه ورئيس
مجلس الشورى
والوزراء المعنيين بالدفاع الوطنيه
الداخليه الدفاع الامريكيه السياسي الامن
القومي الوزاره المعنيه بالدفاع الوطني
اجتمعنا كلنا في اطار هذا المجلس واتخذنا
قرار تصنيف جماعه الحوثيين
هذا القرار هذا القرار همم اتخذ من قبل
المجلس الدفاع ووجه الحكومه وجهنا المجلس
وجهها مجلس القياده الرئاسه الحكومه
باتخان كافه الاجراءات لي ترجمه هذا
التصنيف الى اجراءات اقتصاديه
واداري
هناك عشرات
الشركات
التابعه للمليشيات الارهابيه همم التي
تقوم بتهريب همم المشتقات النفطيه
الايرانيه الى من الحديده
هناك عشرات او مئات محلات الصرافه التي
تعمل مع الميليشيات
هناك الكثير من
البنوك التي تتعامل مع هذه الشركات ومع
هذه القيادات الحوثيه الارهابيه
الاجراءات بدات اتخذت الحكومه المجموعه
يصعد امام المجتمع الدولي
ويقول لهم ان هذه الاجراءات ستدفعني لا
يعلم الحرب ما هو معلن الحرب
مطار صنعاء نوقف الرحلات ولكن استمرينا
من ناحيه انسان
ولكن المشتقات النفطيه لمن ليس للشركات
التابعه للقيادات الميليشيا الارهابيه
التي تهرب النفط الايراني
نحن رايحين الجوانب الانسانيه بالنسبه
لاهلنا الموجودين في ايطار سيطره
الميليشيات الحوثيه وفي نفس اتخذنا هذه
الاجراءات ومستمرين في هذه الاجراءات
تحديث لهذه القائمه السوداء وحسن يستمر في
هذه الاجراءات والتصعيد
فخامه الرئيس
يعني حتى اقفل هذا الملف وخاصه الموقف
الدولي هناك موقف موحد في في مجلس الامه
تجاه
الازمه اليمنيه لكنه حتى الان لم يترجم
على ارض الواقع في التعامل مع هذه
الميليشيات اسالك لماذا في تقديرهم لم
يترجم هذا الامر وهل هناك حسابات يعني
تحول دون تحرك دولي قوي وصارم في مواجهه
الميليشي الحسين في هذا التوقيت
اخي العزيز اولا المواقف الدوليه هي مواقف
دول
وهذه الدول لها مصالح
ومواقفها دائما تعبر عن هذه المصالح
طبعا لا يمكن ان نضع المجتمع الدولي كله
في سله واحده
طبعا يمكن يكون لبعض الدول تاثير اقوى
على الساحه الدولي
وهناك دول تاثيرها ثانوي
المتعلقه بالمصالح الاشتراكيه في المنطقه
مرتبطه بالملفات الصراع في المنطقه
بالملف الايراني النووي مرتبطه
العلاقه مع ايران قد هي كثيره قضايا كثيره
متشابهه وبالتالي يعني انت تذكر انه اول
زياره كان لي مثلا لدوله اجنبيه خارج
المنطقه العربيه كان زياره لالمانيا
لانه ندرك ان الموقف الالماني موقف مهم
داخل الاتحاد الاوروبي
والحوثيين كانوا يراهنوا كثيرا على على
المواقف الالماني وكان لهم تواجد لعناصرهم
اييه
الناعمه اللي بنسميها اللي تتواجد في
اوروبا وفي امريكا وفي هذه المناطق
وحصل تغير في الموقع الاوروبي حصل صحيح
اوكرانيا مرتبط بدور ايران في اوكرانيا
هذه مسائل ولكن نحن نتكلم عن ما يخصنا في
الجميع ولكن كان التعبير كان واضح همم اول
اداه من الاتحاد الاوروبي كانت واضحه
وشفافه بالنسبه لي جماعه الحوت الازرق
قلنا في بياننا عندما رحبنا لانه هذا لا
يكفي
يمكن تعود الى البيان قلنا انه هذا لا
يكفي نحن نطالب المجتمع الدولي بتصنيف
الحوثيين كجماعه هذا والموقف الامريكي
ربما هو الاهم في هذه الزوجيه
هذا صحيح
في الموقف الامريكي اليوم
ما فيش تغيير في الموقف الامريكي حتى الان
واضح بالنسبه لنا استثناء الادانات من
سفيرهم في اليمن
باستثناء الاحاطه اللي سمعناها من المبعوث
الامريكي امام الكونجرس مرتين وهي كانت
حاطه همم يعني بالنسبه لنا نعتبرها
للمشروع الايراني همم الذي بيتنفذه
بالاشيئات الارهابيه الحريه في اليمن وفي
المنطقه
التواصل القصير فخامه الرئيس الحوار معك
في اكثر من ملف حول
المشاهدين نعود للمتابعه في هذه المقابله
الخاصه
[موسيقى]
مرحبا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام في الجزء
الثاني من هذه المقابله الخاصه مع رئيس
مجلس القياده الرئاسي الدكتور رشاد محمد
حياك الله دكتور دكتور
في القياده السياسيه في اليمن مصر
الكثير من التغيرات والحروب ايضا التي
كانت
الحوثي على مدى التاريخ اليوم اريد ان
اسالك حول الموقف الامريكي من العلاقه بين
ميليش الحوثي وايراني الى اي مدى تتفهم
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه بكل سلطات
البيت الابيض
اشوفك العزيز احنا
اثناء الحروب
التي خاضتها الحكومه مع
المتمردين الحوثيين اللي كنا نسبهم
المتمردين في حينها
طبعا اولا يجب ان يعرف الجميع خالد
يعتقد على ان هذه الميليشيات بدات فقط في
ما بعد 2000
وهذا الكلام غير صحيح
الخلايا الايرانيه بدات تتشكل في اليمن
في عام 83 بالتجامل مع تكوين حزب الله في
لبنان
وكان على راس هذه المجموعه
بدر الدين الحوثي ابو عبد الملك
وسليته صلاح فليته اللي ابو محمد هذا اللي
يسميه المتحدث الرسمي
كانوا هم المسؤولين عن هذه الخلايا
وقاموا بعمليات ارهابيه في صنعاء
قنابل على سينما بلقيس وقتل الحارس
السينما
في تلك الفتره
واعمل اخرى ارهابيه
وتم ضبطهم وسجنهم وبعضهم هربوا الى ايران
ثم عادوا ببساطه حينها مع الحكومه في عام
86 لكن مليشيات الايرانيه بدات تتشكل
اليمن بالتزامن مع مع بدايه التشكيل حزب
الله
عند الجميع ان القضيه الاستراتيجيه وخطه
استراتيجيه يعني ليست ولدت 2000 او 2004
يعني القضيه بدات عوده الخميني وبدايه
المشروع الاستراتيجي للتوسع الايراني في
المنطقه
فيما يتعلق بالعلاقه الايرانيه نحن حاولنا
خلال الحروب كلها اللي اخذتها الحكومه مع
المتمردين في صعده في تلك الفتره
ان نقنع المجتمع الدولي وفي المقدمه
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
ان هناك دعم ايراني غير محدود لهذه
الجماعه
وكان ونسلم ملفات بوثائق وادله متعدده
وكل مكان ياتي وفي امريكا الى صنعاء كلنا
نسلم
ادي لك قصه جانا
الجنرال ماتش الذي كان قائد القوات
المركزيه حين هذه 2010
جاءنا الى صنعاء وكان التقيته عملت لهم
عزومه غدا وكنا في نادي ضباط الجيش
يعني هذا ملف يثبت وهو الملف رقم 20
حول علاقه ايران ودعمها للمتمردين فيصل
ولكن دائما يقولون ان الادله غير كافيه
ممكن يكون دلتكم
فقلت له ما رايك انا اسلمك الان ملف وهذا
يمكن الملف 20 قال لي شوف لا تتعب نفسك
ان هذه جماعه تتبع ايران ومدعومه من ايران
ولكن من يقنع البيت الابيض
هذا في عام 2010
بس هذا للتدريب على المصالح
السياسيه التي يمكن
ان ان تحدد مواقف الدول من هذه الجماعه
قررت في مجلس الدفاتر تصنيف الحوثيين
جماعه ارهابيه كم موقف متقدم بعد همم
انهيار الهجره
اريد ان اسالك لان هناك من يطرح من
المراقبين والمتابعين لماذا لم يتخذ
القرار على مستوى المجلس الرئاسي يعني
يطلع هذا ليس من جزء من هذا لم يطرحه
الكثير فقط من المجلس الدفاع ما هي دلاله
اعتقد ان التساؤل هذا نتيجه لعدم فهم
تشكيله مجلس الدفاع الوطني مجلس الدفاع
الوطني اصلا يشمل كل مؤسسات الدوله يعني
الرئاسه اللي يمثلها رئيس المجلس واعضاء
المجلس
رئيس مجلس النواب رئيس الحكومه رئيس مجلس
الشورى ووزراء المعنيين بالدفاع
وايضا بعض الوزراء المعنيين بالدفاع
المدني والمسائل المتعلقه بالسلم والحرب
وبالتالي في المجلس هذا هو اعلى سلطه
لانه بيشمل الرئاسه ويشمل مجلس النواب
ويشمل الحكومه ويشمل مجلس الشورى وبالتالي
عندما صدر القرار فهو يعتبر يمثل لكل
مؤسسات الدوله وبالتالي نحن عندما اتخذنا
هذا القرار في المجلس كان اقوى مما نتخذه
حتى من لانه هذا بيمثل كل السلطات كل
السلطه
او في المقابل اي دعم من قبل اطراف
الدوليه وخارجيه لهذا القرار يعني الموقف
الامريكي ماذا كان يعني بعد التصني شوف
هذا شيء مهم جدا
لم
ينتقدنا مباشره
اي سفير من السفاره المعتمدين عندنا من
الدول الغربيه على الاطلاق فقط يتساءلون
حول المسائل المتعلقه بالجانب الانسانيه
هل هذا سيؤثر على الجانب الانسانيه الجانب
الاغاثيه على الجانب دور المنظمات الدوليه
التي ستتعامل مع الناس في مناطق سيطره
الحوثيين هذه هل ستؤثر على القطاع الخاص
الوطني
لمؤسسات التابعه لهذه القيادات سيتجه
للمؤسسات والكيانات والافراد الذي اصلا قد
وضعهم التحالف في القائمه السوداء
تحالف وضع مجموعه كبيره جدا من الكيانات
والافراد وللاسف الحكومه اليمنيه لم تضع
هذه العناصر في القائمه
وانت عندما تطالب المجتمع الدولي بتصنيف
الجماعه جماعه ارهابيه ينبغي انت ايضا ان
تبدا ثم الطالب الاخرين بتصنيفه
فنحن اتخذنا هذا القرار
وبالتالي كان هناك
لا اقول موافقه امنيه ولكن لم يحصل اي
انتقاد على الاطلاق من المجتمع الدولي
لهذا القرار ثاني يذهب معك الى الملف كذلك
يعني
لازم اليمنيه فيها كثير من الملفات ملف
مجلس القياده الرئاسي اكثر من ثمانيه اشهر
مره على هذا المجلس الاعلان عنه يعني
اعتقد هي مدتها في اليوم لتقييم عمل مجلس
في كثير من الملفات السياسيه والاقتصاديه
والعسكريه وغيرها
ماذا يقول اليوم المواطن اليمني في الداخل
او حتى في الخارج كم مراقب هناك من يرى
بان هذا المجلس يعيش حاله عجز هناك من يرى
بانه هناك فراغ قاتل في السلطه للمجلس
عادي الى داخل بلاد التعامل مع الملفات لا
مؤسسات الدوله يعني اصبحت بشكل الذي يمكن
ان تعادل تفعيل عملها على الارض لم يستطع
اعضاء المجلس الرئاسي عقد اجتماعاتهم لا
في الداخل ولا في الخارج كما يقولون لنا
نقول لك ماذا يقول هناك كثير لم يتحسن
الوقت الوضع الاقتصادي للمواطن اليمني ولا
حتى الحياه اليوميه
الكل يتحدث بان المجلس اليمني يحمل في
ثنايا يعني بذور الخلاف والنهايه اكثر من
يعني ربما الانسجام والوحده كهف من اهداف
الاعلان عن هذا المجلس وهناك من وصل به
التوصيف لانه قنبله موقوته قافله الانفجار
في اي وقت ماذا يقول رئيس مجلس القياده
رئاسه اليمني بهذا الخصوص
اولا اخي العزيز اريد ان نوضح ذلك
انت تعرف ان كل مؤسسه الدوله انهارت
كلها
كامل المؤسسات الدوله
البنيه التحتيه كلها انهارت
هل تعرف انما الان مكتب مجلس القياده
الرئاسي في عدن
في اربع غرف
مستاجره من ناديه التلال
اللي هو بجانب المعاشات
وبالتالي التقييم في ظل الظروف العاديه
يمكن يكون خلال ثمانيه اشهر
التقديم في هذا الظروف عاديه ممكن يكون
تقييم خلال ثمانيه اشهر لكن في ظل ظروف
استثنائيه في خلال ثمانيه اشهر التقديم لن
يكون لكن انا اريد ان اؤكد لك على اربع
نقاط الرئيسيه
المشروع الايراني واللي تمثله
جماعه الحوثيين الارهابيه في صنعاء اعتبرت
انه اعاده تشكيل هذا المجلس بهذه المكونات
واللي لها ايضا ابعاد عسكريا كما تعرف
هذه اعتبروها عباره عن عاصفه حزم جديده
طبعا في ايران وحزب الله وغيرهم ما عندهم
شبكات اعلاميه واسعه سخروها كلها لتفكيك
واضح وبالتالي
الاعلاميه للاسف يمكن
مع هذه الموجه ربما يكون يعني بحرص منهم
وربما بنوع من
عدم همم معرفه ما يدور لكن انا اريد ان
اقول شيء
اولا مجلس القيادي الرئاسي التزم بمجموعه
من القضايا الرئيسيه
التزم بالعوده الى الداخل
واستمرينا والحكومه مستمره وتقوم بدوره
وعملنا اجتماعات متتاليه
التزمنا باستمرار صرف المرتبات
مستمر الصرف المرتبات وحتى هذه اللحظه رغم
اننا سنعاني مشكله حقيقيه ابتداء من هذا
الشهر المرتبات ويجب ان يكون واضح للجميع
الناس المشكله لانه توقف همم تصدر
منها هجمات
تكلفنا اكثر من 50 مليون دولار الاصلاح
غير الوقت يمكن ياخذ مننا خمسه الى سته
شهور لاصلاح
التجنب اعاده من المؤسسات وبناء المؤسسات
بدانا بمجلس القضاء بدانا بمؤسسه النيابه
بدانا بالمحاكم اليوم تعمل المحاكم
والنيابه والمؤسسات القضائيه على اكمل وجه
في كل
انحاء المناطق المحرره
المجلس اليوم
يكتمل بشكل متواصل
يكون عندنا اجتماع غدا او بعد غدا
اجتماع عبر الزور
لانه
ليس من الضروره ان يتواجد الجميع
مهام ميدانيه وهي الاهم بالنسبه لهم خاصه
الذين
افراد المجلس الرئاسي وتواجد في العاصمه
المؤقته عاديه يعني في اشاره وفي تاكيد
على الوحده وانسجام الموعد سيكون لها هذه
كبيره على المواطنين
هذا ولكن انا بقول لك نحن حتى في الاعلان
اعلان نقل السلطه
يتكلم عن الاجتماعات وقال انه ممكن نجتمع
بشكل مباشر او عن طريق همم او غير مباشر
عليها
لانه اليوم نحنا بنعارك قضايانا كلها
احيانا
عن طريق التواصل غير المباشر
قرارات وعندنا جدول الاعمال اللي يوزع عن
طريق امين السر
من من من عدن كان بسبب خلافات بين المجلس
الانتقالي وبين الحكومه الشرعيه يعني في
هناك خلافات ترجمت على ارض الواقع برفض
المجلس الانتقالي حتى لوصول رشاد العلي
هناك من روج لهذا الكلام هذه صحيح
صحيح
المواقع الاعلاميه
والمطابخ الاعلاميه اشتغالات
ممنوع من العوده الى عدن انه عيدروس محبوس
في الامارات انه فلان الفلاني هذا الكلام
ليس له اساس من الصحه
وجلست اسبوع ثم عدت الى القمه الذي القمه
الصينيه العربيه والان عائد الى عدن
الاخ عيدروس تواصلت معه امس وهو الامس
بنتواصل يوميا بالتلفون وسياتي الى الرياض
وجنتحرك الى عدن مع بعض يعني
انا فقط قبل المغادره قبل ما يغادرنا الى
عدن يمكن بيوم او يومين او يوم ياتي الى
الرياض ويمكن نتحرك كلنا الى عدن انا وهو
قبل الذهاب الى اعدادات
المكتب
والاخوان اعضاء المجلس يقدمه مقترحات
وجدول الاعمال يروح من السر ويعمل لنا
جدول الاعمال ونرسله للاخوان همم اعضاء
المجلس ونعمل الاجتماع جدول
القضاء لكن هناك من يطرح ان هناك امر بالغ
الهم لاهميه ويعتبر همم يعني الخطوه رقم
واحد لمواجهه الميليشي الحوتيه وهو اعاده
دمج وتنظيمات التشكيلات العسكريه في اليمن
شكلتم لجناه عسكريه من 59 61 انا معلوماتي
قديمه معلش ههه ما الذي تم في هذه الاجنحه
حتى لا ما هي نتائج
انا اعتبر انها من افضل اللجان التي تعمل
حتى الان مع مجلس القياده الرئيس
اولا هذه اللجنه من 61 شخص
بتمثل نخبه من القيادات العسكريه من كل
الوحدات العسكريه والتشكيلات هذا واحد
اثنين
براسه وهو كان اول وزير دفاع عند بعد
الوحده في عام 90
وهذه اللجنه همم انجزت خطتها
ورفعتها لمجلس القياده الرئاسي
وتم المصادقه على هذه الخطه
ايضا همم
اتى رئيس اللجنه الى الرياض
ومع اعضاء قياده اللجنه
والتقوى ايضا مع الاخوه في العمليات
المشتركه
اخذنا بعض النصائح الام بملاحظاتهم حول
هذه القضيه
[موسيقى]
النزول الميداني الى كل التشكيلات
العسكريه وكل المناطق وكل المحاور
وعملهم مستمر في هذه اللحظه الذي يتكلم
معك فيها وهذه اللجان الان تتحرك من منطقه
الى اخرى ومن محور الى اخر ومن قياده
تشكيل الى قياده العسكريه
اليوم خلينا نتكلم بصراحه المجلس
الانتقالي
وغيرها من يعني المليشيات او
التحدث عن التشكيلات العسكريه
سبع مناطق عسكريه
وهذه الذي بتتبع اصلا كانت وزاره الدفاع
وزاره الدفاع
عندنا تشكيلات عندنا تشكيله المجلس
الانتقالي تشكيلات العمالقه وحراس
الجمهوريه
وعندنا بعد ذلك همم
المحور صعدك اللي يسمى محور الصاعده
هذه الان ال ال هذه اللجنه بتمثل كل هذه
التشكيلات بدون استثناء
وبالتالي النزول الميداني الان سيشمل كل
هذه التشكيلات
وساطلع اللجنه بمجموعه من النتائج
والخلاصات الميدانيه والتوصيات لمجلس
القياده الرئاسي في سبيل تنفيذ المهام
الوارده في اعلان النقل السلطه ما هو موقف
المجلس الانتقالي من هذا الدمج حلو معها
نشوف احنا عندنا ثلاث مراحل يجب ان يكون
واضح للجميع احنا عندنا ثلاث مراحل
المرحله الاولى المرحله الاولى هو انشاء
غرفه عمليات مشتركه واحد والان بدانا فعلا
باعداد هذه الغرفه
في عدن
المرحله الثانيه توحيد مسرح العمليات
توحيد مسرح العمليات بحيث انه تكون هذه
الغرفه ممثل فيها كافه التشكيلات والوحدات
العسكريه بحيث انه كل الجبهات العسكريه
تتلقى تعليماتها من هذه من هذه الغرفه
وبين غرفه عمليات واحده هذه المرحله
الثانيه المرحله الثالثه وهي مرحله الدم
هذه مرحله 30 متاخره
زمني معين حتى تصل الى هذا الهدف هذه
النتيجه
لا نستطيع الان مثلا ان انا اجي اخذ
القوات
المسلحه العمليات واعيد توزيعه انت يمكن
هذا يخل
يخلف
وبالتالي اللجنه العسكريه والامنيه
سابقه كشفت عن الفساد في القطاع العسكري
بجميع التشكيلات واسماء اسماءهم مكرره
بعشرات وين وصلتوا في هذا الملف اليوم
هذا من مهام اللجنه العسكريه والامنيه
اللجنه العسكريه والامنيه الان طلبت
البيانات
طلبت بيانات وزاره الدفاع طلبت بيانات
وزاره الداخليه طلبت البيانات من
التشكيلات العسكريه هذه البيانات
سيتم خضاعها للفحص من قبل هذه الليله
وسيتم مقارنه
سواء في اطار الوزاره مع التشكيلات وزاره
الدفاع الداخليه او في اطار المقارنه مع
وزاره الخدمه المدنيه وبالتالي نستطيع بعد
ذلك ان نخرج من هذه
يعني محاسبتها
على الفساد فخامه الرئيس
نحن نحن لا يمكن ان نسكت على فساد موجود
على الاطلاق ولكن
كائنا من كان يعني ستحاسبون اي شخص متورط
مهما كان هذا الشخص اذا اجتمعت الادله
التي تدين هل تعد بذلك يعني انا اقول فيما
يتعلق بهذا الموضوع فيما يتعلق بهذا
الموضوع نحن نترك الين العسكريه والامنيه
اولا ان تنجز مهمه هذا واحد ثم بعد ذلك ان
نستخلص توصيات هذه الليله وفي اطار هذه
التوصيات التي سترفع اللجنه للمجلس
القيادي الرئاسي سيتخذ المجلس القرارات
المناسبه وفقا لهذه التوصيل في الفتره
الاخيره يعني الخلاف الصامت بين اعضاء
المجلس اللي كان في فتره السابقه ظهر يعني
من القاع الى القمه وصار فيه نبش في
الفساد في ملفات الفساد بين اكثر من طرف
التهامات متبادله من اعضاء المجلس همم الى
المجلس الانتقالي في المقابل هناك
التهامات اخرى كذلك بل نقشتم او فتحتهم
هذا الملف اولا اخي العزيز لا يوجد
التهامات بل اي عضو من اعظم مجلس القياده
الرئاسي لم يصدر من اي عضو من اعضاء
المجلس على الاطلاق اي اتهام من هذا النوع
او حديث
على الاطلاق وانا اجزم بهذا باعتباري رئيس
المجلس واتحمل مسؤوليت هذا الكلام نحن
نظام تعددي
نحن ومكونات سياسيه ولدينا احزان
ولدينا منظمات
الكل يعبر وبالتالي
نحن لا نسكت هذه الاصوات
يتكلمون ولكن ما اكد لكنه هذا الخلافات
ليس داخل المجلس ليس داخل المنزل
تقييمكم للعلاقه في المجلس بين اركان
التحالف
الابداع كده الشرعيه في اليمن كيف تقيم
العلاقات السعوديه اليمنيه العلاقات
اليمنيه الاماراتيه وغيرها يعني
انا اعتقد فيما يتعلق بالعلاقتنا بالتحالف
اخي العزيز اولا انا اريد ان اكل شيء
نحن نحن نؤمن ولدينا ادراك في في مجلس
القياده الرياسي والحكومه
ان علاقتنا الاستراتيجيه مع المملكه
العربيه السعوديه كقاعده لهذا التحالف هي
علاقه تاريخيه
من منطلق مش عاطفي وانما من منطلق مصلحه
الشعب اليمن انت تعرف انه اولا لدينا 1400
كم حدود بريه مع المملكه العربيه السعوديه
لدينا الاف القرى على الحدود اليمنيه
السعوديه
جزء منها في الجانب اليمنيوس في الجانب
السعودي
واحيانا يكون الشيخ للقبيله في في الاراضي
السعوديه واحنا يكون في الاراضي
لدينا اكثر من اثنين مليون يمني مقيمين في
المملكه
العدد الرسمي ممكن يكون
25% وانت تعرف هذا الكلام والكل يعرف 25%
خارجي العدد الرسمي
هناك تحويلات
في الداخل
غير المساعدات التنمويه الذين تلقاها من
خلال البرنامج الاعمال السعودي او من خلال
مركز الملك سلمان او من خلال الدعم
المباشر
مشتقات النفطيه همم الخدمات عندك اليوم
مستشفى عدن الذي ستدير شركه سعوديه ااه
سيقدم التطبيب مجانا الان بدا يفتتح
العيادات الخارجيه من اول امس اليوم
بيقولوا لي في عدن ان هناك مئات ماسكين
طوابير باب المستشفى لانه العلاج مجاني
يعني سيستفيد منه اكثر من نصف مليون مواطن
يمني هذا في اطار تحسين الخدمات طبعا في
عدن همم هناك اداره الامارات ستقدم 120
ميجا بالطاقه الشمسيه همم في بير احمد همم
يمكن الان سيبدا تنفيذه وسيبدا يمكن همم
يعني عملوا في واحد يونيو
انا بتكلم عن هذه العلاقه الاستراتيجيه
بيننا وبين المملكه هي علاقه
نابعه من مصلحه الشعب الذين
الحوثيين غلبوا مصلحه ايران على مصلحه
الشعب
ولكن الشعب اليمني وائل هذه المساله
والدليل على ذلك
الدليل على ذلك
26 سبتمبر 62 هي ميلاد النظام الجمهوري في
اليمن
اليمنيين في 26 الماضي
احتفلوا في شوارع صنعاء
رغم القمع الحسين وهي رساله
للمليشيات الايرانيه
عندما فاز المنتخب السعودي على الارجنتين
اختفى لليمنيين في صنعاء اكثر من اي منطقه
اخرى في اليمن لماذا هو رابط مباشر
ويشجعوا الفريق
الايرانيين احتفلوا بانتصار
الفريق السعودي هذا هذا الرابط غير مباشر
اريد ان اوجه تحيه
لكل المقاتلين من الجيش الوطني من
المقاومه التشكيلات العسكريه المختلفه
التي اليوم تقاتل الحوثيين في كل الجبهات
ونقول لهم انا معهم
وسندعم صمودهم وسرقت معهم
وان هذا وهن هذا الانقلاب
المدعوم ايرانيا
يقبل الشعب اليمني بهذا الوجود الايراني
على الاطلاق الرساله الثانيه لاخواننا في
صنعاء والمناطق التي تحصل
الارهابيه انا اقول لهم اننا معه وان كل
التنازلات اللي قدمناها ليست من اجل
للشيعه الارهابيه الحوثيين احنا قدمناها
من اجلهم لانهم اهلنا وسرقناهم
ونقول لهم انه من بدا يطالب بصرف المرتبات
هو نحن ويعود الى خطابي امام البرلمان في
عدن اللي جاي المشكله مع المرتبات هو
الحوثي لماذا اصدر مدونه السلوك
مدونه السلوك تنص على انه من لا يوالي
الميليشيات الارهابيه
اسطوري
الذي وقفته تعز في مواجهه المشروع
الايراني
نحن اليوم معكم ونحن اليوم بينكم اليوم
همم نعطي اولويه للخدمات في هذه المحاضرات
نعطي اولويه للخدمات في محافظه عدن نعطي
اولويه لاعاده بناء المؤسسات في محافظه
عدن
نموذج للدوله القويه
وتكون ااا نموذج
ماذا تقول لهم في في المحافظات الجنوبيه
ماذا يكون رئيس مجلس القياده الرسمي انا
اقول لي شوف انا اريد ان اقول لك شيء
الفوضى الفوضى نحن نقول اليوم ليس من
مصلحه
المحافظات الجنوبيه ولا من اي طرف في
المحافظه الجنوبيه عدم استقرار المحافظات
الجنوبيه اليوم الذي يدفع لعدم استقرار
المحافظات الجنوبيه هم الحوثيين لماذا لكي
يسقطوا مجلس الرئاسه ولكي يكون هم يقولوا
للمواطنين نحن الميليشيات النموذج الافضل
لكم وليس مجلس القياده الرئاسي هو الحكومه
الشرعيه
لانها لا تتحرك في مناطق وبلدان عملها
للحشد الدعم للمجلس في مواجهه الحوثيين في
المعركه
هل ما اثير من فساد لهذه البعثات يعني من
خلال تعيين المئات من من اقارب كبار
المسؤولين من خارج السلك الدبلوماسي في
السفاره هل كان هو السبب
لذلك وكيف تعملون ايضا على معالجه هذه
القضيه وهذا الملف
شكرا على هذا السؤال اخي العزيز
اولا فيما يتعلق بالدبلوماسيه اليمنيه انت
تعرف ان الانقلاب همم
الميليشيات الايرانيه في صنعاء سيطر على
مؤسسه الدوله بصراحه
[موسيقى]
وكانت البعثات الدبلوماسيه في الخارج همم
بين الولاء للحكومه الشرعيه في المنفى
وبين الولاء
هناك تدمر الجهاز الدبلوماسي حتى انا كنا
تدمر حتى لما كنا نحاول نهرب بعض الموظفين
الدبلوماسيين من صنعاء الى هنا المؤهلين
لكي نعينهم في في بعثات الدبلوماسيه كلام
نلاقي صعوبه وتهديدات لهم وليسرهم من قبل
والمصادره وممتلكاتهم كثير من الناس
الشرعيه تمام والكفاءه فكانت التركيز على
الولاء
كان التركيز على الولد الشرعيه
عناصر ليس لهم علاقه بالجهاز على الاطلاق
ولكن عملت
اشتغلت في الخارج يكفي انها حافظت على
الهويه اليمنيه يعني الدوله اليمنيه بقيت
قائمه السفارات قائمه الجوازات اليمنيه
يتحرك
وانا اقول لك من خلال السنه الماضيه الان
احنا يعني تقريبا كان عندنا 300 و46
تقريبا اااه
دبلوماسي في الخارج نزل الى همم
376 نزلنا الى حوالي 326 همم لدينا
ملحقيات كانهم الحقيقيات 121
ملحق همم نزلناهم الى 91 خلال سنه الان
الحكومه بتناقش تقرير عن الملحقيات يمكن
يتم اختصارها الى 10 الى 15 من الحقيقه
سيتم ايضا مراجعه همم الكشوفات الاسماء
الذي من داخل الشركه
في الفلسفه
طيب
نشوف العناصر اللي همم تعينت خارج الشركه
الدبلوماسي ونحيلهم للخدمه المدنيه
والعناصر اللي في السلك الدبلوماسي يتم
ايضا اعاده تاهيلهم
وترتيبهم واعاده موضوعهم اختصار السفارات
بدل ما يكون انا عندي عشر سفارات في 15
سفاره في اوروبا انا يمكن نكتفي بثلاث
اربع سفارات يعني هناك عمليه
المتورطين الذين ثبت تورطهم في الفساد
هذول كيف سيتم التعامل معهم
اخي العزيز خالد نحن اولا همم نعالج
المشكله نعالج المشكله ثم بعد ذلك بعد ما
نعالج المشكله ننظر في المسببات واسبابها
واذا راينا ان هناك من يستحق المحاسبه
ايضا وجهتهم في اطار ملف ربما الفساد
ومعالجته وجاءتهم همم كذلك معالجه الوضع
في وزاره التعليم العالي مشاكل
همم الحكومه بناءا على التوجيهات هذه
وشكله تلاقينا الان من الحكومه ومن القضاء
والجهاز المركزيه الرقابه والمحاسبه ستقوم
بحصر كل الطلاب المستحقين في الخارج الذي
غير مستحق همم للبعثات سيتم استبعاده
والذي مستحق سيتم تثبيته هذا واحد اثنين
نحن خفضنا الحكومه بصراحه بدلات جهود غير
عاديه خلال السنتين الماضي خفضت فاتوره
الابتاعه الخارجي من 12 مليون دولار في
السنه الى 7,000,000$ من 2019 الى الان
رئيس مجلس القياده الرئاسي الدكتور رشاد
محمد العلي اشكرك شكرا جزيلا على تواجدك
معنا في هذا في هذه المقابله الخاصه شكرا
جزيلا شكرا خالد شكرا بالعربيه وشكرا
للطاقه ايضا وان شاء الله همم اوعدك نلتقي
في لقاء ذلك ان شاء الله شكرا لكم انتم
ايضا هذه كانت مقابله خاصه مع الدكتور
رشاد محمد العليمي رئيس مجلس القياده همم
الرئاسي شكرا لطيب المتابعه وتحيه لكم
طاقم العمل والسلام عليكم
[موسيقى]